it's a good thing i waited 33 years to
bench press because otherwise i might
have done it wrong hey it's evan
carmichael and like andrew huberman says
for any of us success in any endeavor is
very closely related to how much focus
we can bring to that endeavor so let's
help you bring more focus to your
endeavor with andrew hueberman and my
take on his top 10 rules of success i'm
gonna go now so thanks so much i really
appreciate your time thank you
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one focus
for any of us success in any endeavor is
very closely related to how much focus
we can bring to that endeavor
and the reward system you start to
realize is entirely internal no one's
coming along and cramming dopamine in
your ear or dripping it in your brain
it's all internal and this starts to
bring us into the kind of like
discussion around mindsets because so my
colleague carol dweck who you know
popularized this growth mindset
it's again a very misunderstood concept
it's the idea that we can change so
that's built into that but the discovery
of growth mindset was of these kids that
actually really enjoyed doing problem
sets that they knew they couldn't get
right but for them they would get this
like dopamine release from just focusing
on the problem they like doing puzzles
they couldn't get right it sounds crazy
but inevitably those kids are very good
at puzzles and very good at math and on
these kinds of things so growth mindset
is i believe it was sort of a
neuroscience lens on growth mindset
would be that the agitation and stress
that you feel at the beginning of
something and when you're trying to lean
into it you can't focus is just a
recognized gait you have to pass that
through that gate to get to the focus
component and then if you can reward the
effort process you really start to feel
joy
and low levels of excitement in the
effort process that's that buffering of
adrenaline that's that feeling like yes
i've got a lot of adrenaline in my
system but i'm on the right path
it feels good to walk up this hill so to
speak
and when you start to bring those neural
circuits together
you really start to create a whole set
of circuits that are designed to be
exported to any behavior you want
so if it's writing a book great if it's
podcasting great if it's building a
business great if it's if it's
you know building a terrific
relationship great then the circuits
that mother nature has designed are
incredibly generic so that we could
adapt to whatever it is that we need to
do and i think the misunderstanding
around how these circuits work has led
to this idea that there's some secret
entry point maybe marked flow on the
door and there's a trampoline up to that
door and you just open that door and
you're going to be in it right and
nothing could be further from the truth
and anyone who's done well in any career
or athletic pursuit knows this
but unfortunately there's a kind of
obsession with the idea that it's all
supposed to feel good and it does feel
good but there's a whole staircase in
which it feels kind of lousy rule number
two replace negative thoughts i'm never
going to argue that we can subjectively
control all of our experience because
there are some things that just
genuinely suck right and when they and
it's important to and it's important to
register those those not so great events
or terrible events because they can
drive us also you know we can be driven
from a place of anger frustration and
and you know revenge or we can be driven
from a place of you know love gratitude
and etc i i'm not here to judge which
one is better or worse but the nervous
system doesn't distinguish between them
so if you're the kind of person that
needs to you know kind of budge yourself
into something great if you're the kind
of person that wants to do things from
more of a warm fuzzy feeling that's fine
too what i will say is this the ability
to tap into this dopamine reward system
which
is activated anytime you're in pursuit
of something that's outside the
boundaries of your skin and literally
the boundaries of your body as well as
the reward system the serotonin oxytocin
system which is really about the things
that are contained within your own body
and immediate experience things like
gratitude and you know
touch and comfort and things like that
with loved ones the ability to tap into
both is crucial now you said something
really important which was well negative
thoughts
negative thoughts what to do i don't
believe that it's very easy to suppress
negative thoughts
however when you realize that thoughts
can be deliberately introduced you can
start replacing negative thoughts with
new types of thoughts so you can always
add something in but when people start
to realize that thoughts are very much
like physical actions of reaching and
picking up a glass of water or taking a
jog around the ball block or typing an
email perfectly this is something i
sometimes do because i'm i you know i
struggle to do the perfect email not all
my emails are perfect but when i do one
i make sure that i i complete and i
think okay it's possible it's not
because the email being perfect is so
important it's because i want to remind
myself that my thoughts and my actions
are essentially the same the nervous
system can organize thoughts so for
somebody that's struggling
you know we have these examples like oh
they were really back on their heels or
they were so depleted no money and all
this stuff what are they gonna we have
so many examples like that but in trying
to make it actionable it's really about
saying yep that's all true
but i'm going to introduce a thought
which is i made it through today
i'm
i made it through today and that's
actually worth celebrating at a micro
level so if you can give yourself
dopamine rewards in small increments
right you're not trying to celebrate
that you made it through one day
sometimes that's a huge feat but most of
the time you just want to dose yourself
with a little bit of that internal
release of dopamine
you start rewarding incremental steps
and if there's anything that your
listeners could take away from this
whole thing about dopamine and reward
schedules and being in movement it's
reward incremental steps
in particular
incremental steps that are about forward
action so maybe that's writing an email
maybe that's um maybe that's that run
around the block maybe that's something
much grander for you as you get better
at things right the stairs get further
and further away from one another
because you've achieved more success and
so they tend to be you have to take the
rungs on the ladder further apart so to
speak that's a time when you really need
to implement not only the dopamine
rewards but also those serotonin and
oxytocin rewards etc so to make it
actionable
i would say remember don't spend so much
time trying to suppress negative
thoughts if you need trauma therapy
pursue that with a professional but if
you have negative thoughts just remember
i can also introduce positive thoughts
the same way i can control running
around the block positive thoughts are
the equivalent of forward physical
action and if you reward them internally
you buffer yourself against the quitting
circuit this norepinephrine circuit we
were talking about before you are
building a stronger version of yourself
completely between your own ears and
some people say well that's silly it's
like you're saying oh i'm going to jump
up and down reward myself for doing
nothing no you're building the neural
circuits that reward that you can
control self-reward and in doing that
you can push through days and weeks of
effort consistently i don't mean
necessarily all-nighters but you can
push and push and push rule number three
reward the progress growth mindset which
is the academic discovery and laboratory
discovery of my colleague carol dweck at
stanford is the hallmark of growth
mindset is really two things
one is i'm not where i want to be now
but i but i will i'm capable of getting
there eventually the other is to attach
a sense of reward to the effort process
itself in fact don't reward the result
reward the effort that's right and if
you look at true high performers people
that are consistently good at what they
do they don't peak and go through the
postpartum depression and crash and come
back and their life is a cycle of ups
and downs but really people who are on
that upward trajectory consistently
those people attached dopamine
to the effort process and actually
carol's one of her original studies on
the discovery of growth mindset was
these kids that loved doing math
problems that they knew they couldn't
get right so it's like the people love
puzzles but in this case they knew they
couldn't get it right but they loved
doing it and it incidentally or not so
instead only these kids are fantastic at
math when there is a right answer
because they're
they feel some sense of reward from the
effort process yeah now the cool thing
about dopamine
is that it's very subjectively
controlled we can all learn to secrete
dopamine in our brain
in response to things
that are in a purely subjective way
our interpretation our interpretation
and but it has to be
attached to reality so you know one
should never confuse what is real right
so no so if you're if you're thinking
about the effort you're expending so
let's say somebody right now is
financially back on their heels and
they're setting up a new business for
instance and it's hard
if they can take a few moments or
minutes each day to reflect on
the fact that the effort process is
allowing them to climb out of their hole
potentially that it's giving them an
opportunity that it's
somehow
they are on the right path or if they're
not in movement along that path or at
least oriented on the right path they're
not lying in bed all day they're
thinking
they're taking a step if they can reward
that process internally two things
happen
first of all the brain circuits that are
associated with building subjective
rewards and dopamine gets stronger so
you get better at that process and
second and most importantly dopamine has
an amazing ability to buffer adrenaline
and buffer epinephrine and what i mean
by that is there was a study that was
published in the journal cell excellent
journal cell press journal a couple
years ago showing that with repeated
bouts of effort we use
and we release more and more epinephrine
it's kind of adrenaline but in the brain
with more effort every time every time
you put in effort so every time you make
for this let's keep it if i were to keep
it in the business context every time
you make to write that email every time
you let's see it's a person who's a
craftsman or crafts woman every time
you're working in the in the shop and
doing that every bit of effort
you're
taking a little bit of money out of this
epinephrine account you're spending
epinephrine at some point
those levels of epinephrine get high
enough
that you you feel like quitting it feels
exhausted
this was done in a beautiful study
actually where um they control the
visual environments and they have the
subjects ex exert effort and they can
control the visual environment so
sometimes the effort of taking steps and
moving forward is actually kind of
pushing forward and kind of swimming
motion um
would give them the sensation that they
were actually making progress and other
times it was an exercise in futility
where they would just keep the visual
world stationary and they would expend
effort and they didn't think they were
going anywhere
epinephrine's climbing climbing climbing
and eventually
they quit
now dopamine is able to push back on
that epinephrine and give you
anyone the the feeling that you could
continue and maybe even the feeling that
you want to continue and you've seen
this actually football is a good example
two teams play
say the super bowl
both teams are max effort the entire
time yeah max effort
the team that wins suddenly in a moment
has the energy to jump all over the
place party for days they can talk i
mean they they they exhausted right
before that well that wasn't glycogen or
stored energy of any kind except it was
neural energy and what happened was
effort is this adrenaline adrenaline
adrenaline adrenaline eventually people
quit they just quit
the
dopamine is able to suppress that and so
then you're expending effort but you're
doing it from a place of feeling like
you have energy for it rule number four
detach from external rewards there was a
paper published
that essentially was asking why any
human or animal quits at any behavior
now certain behavior is like i can't
lift a car unless it's a very small car
i can't lift a car but if it's we're
talking about running or we're talking
about
long bouts of work the question is why
do we quit like what is that it turns
out that every time we exert effort a
certain amount of noradrenaline in the
brain is released and there's a sort of
a counter in the brain stem and at some
point enough no adrenaline is released
and it shuts down
cognitive control deliberate control
over the motor circuitry and we quit
that's it but the thing that can restore
those levels or it can sort of reset
those levels lower and give us more gas
more mileage is dopamine and it makes
perfect sense because our species had to
move against very challenging things in
in nature and in in terms of in culture
at every stage of our evolution
including now 2020 is a good example of
this and when a good example would be
if you're really slogging it out and
things are miserable just think like the
worst family vacation everything is a
disaster or a very hard physical event
and someone cracks a joke
you almost immediately feel a sense of
relief
you see this in the team that wins the
super bowl both teams slogged it out you
have to believe they were both at max
effort the entire game look at the team
that wins they have extra energy they're
jumping all over the place so it can't
be physical energy it can't be glycogen
related it's not ketone related it's
nothing in the body in that sense it's
dopamine's ability to take that level of
norepinephrine and smack it back down
and so we can
learn this right i mean i think this is
where there's real power like in your
story
or the story that i'm familiar with
from your book like the the ability to
push through
those pain points is something that we
really can export to other aspects of
life because it's the same
neurochemicals that are involved so when
you get to a particular location or
maybe i
recall um you know a portion where
you're just you're feeling lousy you
know you're injured or you feel like
you're hurt and you can reframe it
mentally
and think i'm actually still on the
ladder i'm still holding on to a wrong i
know at least that much i'm still
breathing i know that much and the lift
that we get is not some psychological
pump up it's a neurochemical thing it's
dopamine suppressing norepinephrine and
saying you're on the right path you can
keep going it's a permission to keep
going and we grant that permission to
ourselves no one grants that permission
to us i think one of the other kind of
misconceptions that we want to dissolve
is this idea that
external rewards can actually propel us
down long paths of of success and high
performance they can't no it's a
internal sustainable fuel source yeah
yeah i have a friend from the seal teams
and somebody asked us recently we were
given a talk
and somebody said how can i make sure
that i continue to self-reward and i'm
not driven by these um external rewards
how can i continue to have that drive
and uh his answer was very good he said
give away all the external rewards you
know now not all everyone can afford to
do it it's just about you and you it's
just you and you and the more attached
there's a famous stanford study done at
bing nursery school probably not far
from where you were in the dormitory
there's a little nursery school in
escondido village and they did this
study where they looked at kids that
liked to um playing during their recess
it's all recess in nursery school but
they're drawing
and they took the kids that really like
to draw
and they started giving them little gold
stars on their drawings
and then they like the gold stars for a
kid that's an extrinsic reward and then
they stopped doing that and the kids
stopped drawing
they just they they associated the good
feeling of doing it with the external
rewards we have to be very cautious
about how much of our internal dopamine
we attach to external rewards if we want
to continue to grow
and pursue and focus and work hard if
you just want to get to some place and
cash in
then fine but most people find
themselves in a pretty miserable place
because their dopamine was so attached
to external rewards they need more and
more of well
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five try hypnosis
when people think of hypnosis i think
they think of stage hypnosis what's the
real deal why is it useful and and how
do people actually use it yeah so um i'm
really glad you asked about this so i
have a colleague his name is david
spiegel in our department of psychiatry
at stanford and he and i have a
collaboration going now looking at how
respiration or breathing can be used to
shift the brain into different states
and i've talked to david about this and
so i'm sort of borrowing from his words
here so i want to be fair that these are
from those conversations
so hypnosis inevitably involves relaxing
the nervous system taking the nervous
system into states that are more like
sleep now what i mean by that is in high
alert states where you're talking and
planning and inaction and stress in
particular
the brain is very linear it's saying
okay if this then this if then then this
is why we tend to be forward thinking
when when we're stressed we tend to be
not in our immediate experience but
really kind of forward thinking so
clinical hypnosis involves
going into a state of deeper relaxation
so that our analysis of space and time
meaning the way that the brain is
perceiving events is slightly
dismantled so that it's a little bit
dreamlike and then the hypnotist and
this could be by listening to a script
or listening to a hypnotherapist
starts to narrow our context take our
thoughts if you will it down a
particular path and that path could be
one of um stress reduction or a smoking
cessation um hypnosis is incidentally is
very good for treatment of smoking
cessation or
for feelings of well-being or
confronting traumas so what it is is
it's really opening up the window for
neural plasticity which is of course the
brain's ability to change in response to
experience to trigger neuroplasticity
you have to have focus especially as an
adult you need acetylcholine released
but
high levels of attention acetylcholine
and norepinephrine together
norepinephrine to create that sense of
urgency and acetylcholine to bring that
spotlight of focus in really really
tight that triggers plasticity but the
actual it marks certain synapses in the
brain for change but the actual changes
in the synapses the rewiring okay that
happens during states of sleep and deep
rest so this is why when you're trying
to learn a motor skill you go and you go
in your tennis serve it's not happening
it's not happening you take a break you
come back and you nail it you're like
wait what happened well you need time to
set those circuits in motion and allow
them to do to the rewire and the sort of
adaptation hypnosis seems to capture
both the high attentional state and the
deep relaxation at the same time it's
this very unusual state of mind where
you're neither asleep nor awake and in
tight focus or narrow focus and it's
very clear that it leads to these rapid
changes in behavior because you're
rewiring the brain and the reason you're
able to rewire the brain so quickly is
because you're getting the trigger event
the focus
and you're also getting the relaxation
event simultaneously and so it's much
faster than separating out the learning
trigger from the actual rewiring of the
brain rule number six practice releasing
dopamine dopamine is not just about
reward it's one of the biggest
misconceptions dopamine is about
motivation
and drive it's like a jet that propels
you along a path
how do we get more dopamine you practice
subjectively releasing dopamine in your
mind like wow okay so
that's a great question first of all
there are ways you can get more dopamine
release through thoughts or through
drugs or through supplements i want to
be really clear there is a drug there
are two drugs actually that will cause
massive release of dopamine they're
called cocaine and methamphetamine
the problem gets us addicted because it
feels so good the problem is exactly the
problem is cocaine and methamphetamine
stimulate so much dopamine release
that the
drug becomes the only source it becomes
the goal
it becomes the path and the destination
and you look at people's lives when they
do a lot of cocaine and methamphetamine
and that baseline on their life goes
down dopamine is this incredibly
powerful molecule that allows us to
buffer the effort process it allows us
to be an effort longer and it allows us
to actually eventually enjoy the process
of effort and not think about the reward
but just say oh i'm enjoying the process
right well you just described the first
step the first step in learning to
attach dopamine to the effort process
which is the key
operation in order to succeed is to
be very careful about how much you focus
on the end goal keeping the goal in mind
is important for like a proper
orientation you have to know the
ultimate destination but if at any point
we were to evaluate our progress
relative to that end goal
or if we don't know what the end goal is
there's a huge gap there and it can feel
overwhelming the key to this is if we
want to be very concrete we should
probably focus on actions and i'll use
fitness as an example because it
translates to everybody whereas you know
people's circumstances is different
let's say somebody really wants to take
on a fitness routine
they hate running or they want to lose
weight in a healthy way this kind of
thing so we've all heard the example
well you put your shoes by the door on
day one day two you put them on day
three you go out the door day four you
walk around the block and then you know
and then eventually like they're running
marathons okay
great but to sustain that behavior or
even to make the behavior pleasureful
and to give you energy the key is to
subjectively reward those steps so it's
not going to be let's say i go out and i
run a mile
and my goal is to run 10 miles in a few
weeks the key is as you're in the strain
of that mile the hard part you want to
tell yourself
this is the good part this is the part
that gives me energy and i'll be very
surprised if people don't actually feel
like they could continue further so it's
a journey of a thousand miles starts
with a single is made up of you know
single steps but the key is to reward
the harder steps not the easier ones and
not the ones where you get the thing
that you want there's a process i'm
going through right now where i'm trying
to write a book and um it's hard and
it's hard and i was told that the harder
it is the better i'm probably doing it
and i was like great and my editor's
ready to kill me and because i'm slow
and i and i know and i'm a very slow
person i i drive people crazy i'm like
glacially slow because science is slow
and i like to get things right i want to
rush it yeah i like to get things right
but i'm very proud of the fact that
everything we've published i can stand
behind it was the best we could do with
the tools at the time and i just know
that when i look back on a writing
career or scientific career i want to be
able to say you know every journal we
put it in was rock solid everything was
rock solid we had fun doing it the
relationship so i go slow yeah but as a
consequence what i'm finding is
there are a lot of interferences these
days i'm i'm i think social media is
great i teach neuroscience on social
media because i think it's important to
do public education
too but it's incredible and it's it's
incredible how much time and energy it
can take so what i've started doing now
is i turn off my phone and i lock it in
safe
and i experience extreme anxiety right
it's so weird why is that is it because
it gives you so much dopamine that when
you're not having it well this is scary
because i actually think um brief
anecdota on the weekend i was driving
there's a kid that i mentor and i picked
up my phone and i was texting while i
was driving and he said to me this was
really embarrassing for me he said
you know i
i wish you wouldn't text while you drive
and i put it and i put it down and i
realized this is crazy i know that i
that my life in his life is far more
important and the lives of the people
around me are far more important than
any text message which means i wasn't
doing it rationally it's just pure
reflex at this point so i would i don't
think i pick up the phone because i'm i
don't even know what i'm looking for
there anymore it's just become reflexive
so
for me lately
the longer i can keep that phone in a
safe and write on a grant or my or this
book
what i tell myself is the agitation is
good i'm it's at least i'm not doing
that and then i find that as i start to
write and i
get into the process i start feeling
good about it and i'll pause and say
okay i i have control i have ultimate
control over my behavior i can put that
thing away there might be a nuclear war
out there and
i'm just doing this anyway i have
control over my thoughts my feelings and
behavior so i tell myself that and then
i find i have immense energy and all i
want to do is write and i kind of tunnel
into the process wow and i think that
sometimes people need to write these
things out for themselves so it's really
concrete i think some people are so
unskilled at subjective rewards that
writing it out is really powerful so
what would you write out for yourself as
a subjective reward for this experience
as long as i'm writing i'm on the right
path
as long as i'm not writing i'm looking
at my phone i'm not on the right path
because for me the the two or three
things that are most important for my
career are writing grants working on
this book manuscript and writing
scientific manuscripts i mean there are
other things that's going on anything
else that you're not doing is is holding
you back from doing that that's right so
you need to be focused center mass
forward on doing those things that's
right so i don't do any jumping around
power poses things like that i will use
tools to kind of ramp up my dope i mean
there are certain songs that are really
embedded in my
my emotional thing that go back to you
know when i was a you know
while you know skateboarding punk rock
teenager that will get me fired up
and i think there's real utility that's
pure dopamine rule number seven think in
processes
hashtag growth mindset is one of the
most popular hashtags in social media
but most people don't actually know what
it means and again this is carol dweck's
discovery not mine it was discovered in
a group of kids that were doing math
problems or other kinds of puzzles that
they knew they couldn't get right but
they enjoy doing them and they perform
exceedingly well on lots of sorts of
tests of that sort
when there is the right answer of course
and so what they do is they somehow
they're wired for effort they're wired
for the puzzle not for the solution and
when i say puzzle i don't mean the noun
puzzle i mean the verb for being puzzled
it for them feels good and so we need to
think uh if we're talking about the
nervous system and we want to make it
actionable for high performance whether
or not it's in business or sport or
otherwise we want to think in terms of
processes not events and verbs not nouns
so growth mindset as a verb as an action
item you know uh reward as a verb not
just as oh you're gonna just pat
yourself on the back like it's no it's
what you internalize it's a process
that's how the neural circuits that
underlie reward get stronger and the
beauty of of the brain is that you have
this thing of neural plasticity which is
its ability to change itself throughout
the whole lifespan and the more you
practice this the better you get at it
and it does not mean you're walking
around talking delusionally about how
great life is when everything is
terrible it means you might even be very
stoic you might be
hopefully you're very rational but you
have the energy to continue to push
forward rule number eight attach meaning
there's an interesting process that
that occurs when people start to realize
that rewards are all internal
and what they start to do is they start
linking this duration path outcome thing
to their internal rewards and so to put
this simply one of the most powerful
things that any person can do is to
learn to control
this idea of duration path and outcome
and attach an internal sense of reward
just that you're doing well to reward
yourself mentally just say i'm doing
well i'm actually on the right path
to do that
inside of the
demands that come from the external
world the more often that we can
self-reward
some aspect of the process provided it's
in the right direction of what we're
trying to achieve
the more energy we're going to have for
that the more focus we're going to have
for that and remember that nor the
reason i say energy i don't throw that
around loosely is that
limiting amount of noradrenaline is
constantly being kept at bay you're
literally buffering the quit response
and so when people start realizing that
if they set the goals inside of the
larger goal and self-reward each one of
those they essentially have an infinite
amount of energy to pursue
those goals they have an infinite amount
of focus to pursue those goals you see
this most uh in the special operations
community and people that are selected
essentially for this process it's one of
the things that's been intriguing to me
i have some friends from the seal teams
and i don't begin to you know really
understand the real work that they do
deployed because i've never done that
kind of work but i've always been
intrigued by the selection process the
so-called buds process right because
carrying logs and
getting in cold water and all that
that's not really how
the work is that's really not what the
work is about so the selection process
is interesting because everyone shows up
fit motivated and convinced that they're
not going to quit i mean i think like
there might be a couple just show up to
show up but everybody is absolutely
convinced and then a very small subset
of them make it through
and i'd be willing to bet that the ones
that make it through
of course they're gritty and resilient
but they all are essentially right so
that's necessary but not sufficient
obviously otherwise everyone would make
it through the people that make it
through somehow are able to tap into a
process maybe it's
a reward process maybe it's through
self-punishment maybe it's through
self-reward um in the positive sense but
they're able to control something inside
an environment that is not controlled by
them it's controlled by the by the
instructors
and
i've always been struck by the fact that
in order to to
not in order to get through you just
have to not quit remember people aren't
being deselected they're not saying get
out of here you're not good enough
you're not people are deciding that for
themselves
and so it's interesting because
it brings about a real world experiment
of people who are quitting and i believe
they're quitting because they can't
manage these neurotransmitters
and the people when i say manage i think
that the people they get through knowing
some of these people quite well
had an internal process by which they
could reward themselves for doing
something that might have just looked
trivial to everybody else but it gave
them more gas more energy right right
and what's interesting is the process
the kind of unconscious genius of of the
buds process is that
they've picked two sensory events
that are across the board challenging
for everybody one is cold water which is
great because it most of the time it
can't kill you
right it's not like heat which can kill
you it's cold water and sleep
deprivation
and so the ability to do these like what
i'm calling dpos this uh duration path
and outcome
steps and procedures is great on when
you're rested you know uh you know when
you have a when you're well-fed well
slept you can do anything you can be in
any hard conversation you can work
through anything so what they do is they
start taking the autonomic nervous
system which is
these deep reserves of the nervous
system
that when our autonomic nervous system
is off it starts making us
pay more attention to how we feel than
the demands of the world around us
remember that yeah basic challenge in
the nervous system and so sleep
deprivation
is the best way that you can pull
somebody down from their ability to
analyze duration path and outcome and
reward themselves sleep deprivation is
the way in which you essentially pull
apart the nervous system and the way
that it wants to function because
it's very easy again rested to do all
this but so what they do is they're
sleep deprived people they put them in
cold water they're trying to get them
more in touch with the way that they
feel inside than what they need to do in
response to the external demands right
everyone i know that's made it through
that process did it slightly differently
but i'll tell you how they didn't do it
they didn't do it through sheer grit and
determination they did it through
attaching a sense of meaning they did it
by
micro
slicing the day or slicing the day into
a series of meals that they just needed
to get to and then rewarding themselves
for getting to that next milestone so
they don't know i mean most of them
you know probably had very low concept
of dopamine and norepinephrine but
that's the process that's also the
process i think that allows someone to
finish an ultra i've never run an ultra
but i think that process of self-reward
is
grit and resilience in a kind of
neurochemical definition yeah and i
think it's a thing that anybody can tap
into and i think it's therefore i think
it's it's so key because i think people
think that
uh it's just so key that people
understand excuse me that these circuits
are not unique
to people who run ultras or people that
make it through
uh you know stringent filter special
operations command
it's the same thing that it is
interesting rule number nine learn
breathing patterns i'm really glad you
mentioned the diaphragm diaphragm of
course being this muscle inside of all
of us at least all mammals that works
all the time to move our lungs because
all the cells in our body need oxygen of
course we get rid of carbon dioxide it
does that but it's done reflexively but
we can also take voluntary control over
it i want to just mention about the
diaphragm why it's so important for what
were these state changes is that a lot
of people talk about the vagus nerve and
all this stuff the vagus and these
connections between the brain and this
vagus nerve or the gut
it's what gets activated when you're
really full and you eat a big meal and
you feel relaxed those are great but
it's very slow
the diaphragm is skeletal muscle just
like your bicep just like your tricep
just like your quadricep it is the only
internal organ except maybe a couple
muscles in your throat that are actually
skeletal muscle meaning it was designed
to be voluntarily moved and the
diaphragm isn't just designed to move
your lungs it also sends a signal
through the so-called phrenic nerve back
to the brain to inform your brain about
the status of your body so when you
breathe fast deliberately the reason you
feel kind of an elevated sense of
alertness is because
yeah their chemicals secrete but mostly
because the phrenic nerve is firing off
it's telling you hey the body's moving
we're really running now even though
you're stationary in a chair if you're
doing breathing or if you're breathing
very slowly and rhythmically right box
type breathing or you know slow slow
breathing
your diaphragm is telling your brain hey
we're calm we're good and you calm down
very quickly on the order of seconds and
so once you start tapping into this you
start realizing okay movement of the
body was designed to inform the brain of
where to be not just the brain telling
the body and how does the body
communicate with the brain through the
phrenic nerve from the diaphragm so my
lab is really pursuing two questions and
this is still being worked out so i just
want to highlight that it's still in
progress
but
certain patterns of breathing will calm
you very much like entering a hypnotic
state and so you have a subset of
neurons in your brain stem that are
responsible for sighing visit you have a
subset of neurons in your brainstem
responsible for for coughing subset of
neurons responsible for laughter and a
subset of neurons in your brainstem for
sign this was a paper published in
nature this is a real thing these
neurons are every so often and your dog
does this too
you inhale twice
and then you exhale long
now that double inhale
best done through the nose on the
inhales and then long exhale through the
mouth
activates these sine neurons that
trigger the so-called calming reflex the
parasympathetic arm of the nervous
system so we have a hard-wired mechanism
a set of neurons connection in the
diaphragm and back again from the
diaphragm to the brain that was designed
to activate calm
and when people ask me how should i
breathe to calm myself down i always say
double inhale through the nose followed
by exhales two or three of those will
reset your autonomic nervous system
faster than any other mechanism we're
aware of
because it's really capitalizing on a
set of neural circuits now once you're
calm you say well how do i get into
plasticity states there you want to go
the other direction
that's going to be inhaling a lot more
than you exhale you're going to be
driving in more oxygen than you are
breathing out
generally carbon dioxide and that will
lead to states that are kind of more
elevated this is typical of things like
tumor breathing wim hof breathing
kundalini breathing and when people
enter those states
their whole world changes because it
shuts off the frontal cortex it really
this is why sometimes people pass out or
they feel like they want to get up and
move you know you get some odd behavior
when you're doing this kind of thing
so the key is if you want to access
states of heightened plasticity let's
say you want to learn faster or you want
to be more um
you want to bring more out of some
physical training that you're doing the
key is to apply those principles first
you need to focus you need to bring
yourself to that heightened state of
alertness you can breathe to do that so
this would be super oxygenated breathing
then you want to drop into a state of
calm and you do that by these a couple
maybe two or three rounds of inhale
inhale exhale inhale inhale exhale and
then now your brain is in a state we
believe this is still again being worked
out in labs like mine and david's but
then you're in a state for heightened
learning
because you're in a state where
neurochemicals like acetylcholine are
going to be at levels that are higher
than they typically would be things like
noradrenaline slightly higher than they
typically would be but not in a
discombobulated way in a very regulated
way and the cool thing is you're
regulating them so you could argue you
know earlier we were talking about
subjective emotions and thoughts and all
these things but one thing that's
absolutely concrete is breathing i
always think of physical exercise
movement writing
whatever singing dancing talking those
are physical actions in the universe
then you have thoughts and somewhere in
between those is controlling your
respiration once you can control
everything that's within the confines of
your skull and skin once you can really
control that relationship that brain
body relationship you start to realize
that relationship is a lot like any
other relationship to forward action
it's just all happening within the
confines of my body so it's heightened
states of focus followed by states of
relaxation that are going to prime your
nervous system for learning and
plasticity just like hypnosis and rule
number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus clips is be deliberate if
i finish a chapter
i will stop for a moment and i'll just
kind of smile and laugh at myself i'm
big on like
self reflection with humor and just
thinking this is crazy you know
my brain is under my control there would
be people out there that say there's no
free will but i do not believe that i
put my hands in a lot of brains you
stimulate certain brain areas people do
things you stimulate other brain areas
people think things
ultimately unless you have electrodes in
your head and someone's stimulating them
we are in control of our thoughts and
behaviors we can't control all of them
but my goal is to be as
you know deliberate and non-reflexive as
possible in life that's my goal from
when i wake up in the morning until i go
to sleep how do we get to that place
little by little and by rewarding each
thing if you get up and you
used to make the bed exam make the bed
you're you're not back on your heels you
make a cup of coffee you sit down you
script out something in a journal you
exercise
maybe you call a relative that you think
might need to hear from you or that
you'd like to talk to you do something
in a deliberate way just being
deliberate and learning to push away the
things that are trying to make you
reflexive is so important
there's a classic experiment in bio in
behavioral biology called the tube test
where you take two mice you put them in
a tube and they try and push each other
out they fight for that tube
and one mouse inevitably pushes out the
other mouse the one that stays in the
tube is the winner the one that got
pushed out is called the loser
what's interesting is that if you take
those same mice
and give them new competitors the one
that won has a much higher than chance
probability
of being a winner the subsequent battle
what's called a battle
the loser has a much higher probability
of losing now that's the first
experiment and you go okay well winners
become winners losers become losers but
it's actually far more interesting than
that because if you take the loser
and you put them against even a known
winner
and you push the loser from behind
the loser becomes the winner and the
winner becomes the loser and even if the
effort that the
loser that became the winner exerted
wasn't their own right you've got a
human pushing with a stick on this
little mouse
so
the important thing is the third
experiment which only arrived a few
years ago this is an experiment that was
published in the journal science um
science and nature are our super bowl
and nba championships of science very 90
99 rejection rates very stringent
thoroughly peer-reviewed not just any
publications
a laboratory not mine
unfortunately uh did the experiment
where they monitored the brains of these
mice while they were doing engaging in
this tube test battle and they found
that there was one brain area it's a
sub-region of the prefrontal cortex not
the whole prefrontal cortex that's more
active in the winter and less active in
the loser
so much so that if you chemically or
electrically activate this brain area in
the loser that loses or becomes the
winner
if you quiet this brain area in the
winter or an animal that's about to win
it suddenly becomes the loser so you say
what in the world is this brain area
doing to the body into the psychology of
these mice now we don't know the
psychology of the mice but they did do
some important controls and they it's
not testosterone although there's a
testosterone increase associated with
winning it is not testosterone in the
moment
it's not cortisol it's not any of the
other normal things that you might think
to look to it's not muscle strain
it turns out
that stimulation of this brain area that
causes winning
is associated with increased anxiety
effort and adrenaline
and all it does is it converts
that anxiety into more steps forward per
unit time literally just steps forward
so if you take this brain area and you
quiet it for a given level of stress the
animal backs up a little bit more or
pauses a little bit more if you
stimulate this brain area for the same
amount of stress
the animal advances a little bit more as
opposed to pauses or backs up and the
thing that's really key to take away
from this for everyone's individual
lives and goals is that if you really
think about it you always have only
three options you can either be
stationary you can back up you can
retreat or you can go forward and you
want to do it you want to move forward
in an adaptive way you don't want to
walk off a cliff or do something stupid
financially or physically but
anxiety and stress and what we call
autonomic arousal were designed to move
us they create a sense of agitation and
discomfort for a reason but it wasn't
just designed to move us to run and hide
it was also designed to move us forward
and a lot of people take the agitation
the fear the anxiety about starting
something new and they try and work with
that and push down on it there's just so
much in our culture that's about trying
to get homeostasis a word that i really
despise
that homeostasis and trying to get back
to this place of calm or flow so they
can move forward and what they don't
appreciate what people haven't been told
because the science is very new
is that all forms of adaptive behavior
in the animal kingdom and in humans
whether or not it's with the mind or the
body or both involve a
fairly high level of stress and anxiety
that was designed to move us forward
and it doesn't have to be just
competition in battle this could be
writing your book this could be uh
finding and the mate that you you know
that you want to find a life mate it
could be
any number of different things that
you're going to pursue there's always
anxiety associated with that and trying
to bypass that could actually represent
the failure of our species one of the
reasons why breathing is such a powerful
tool for shifting one state
is that a it's always available
for voluntary control it's just right
there you can i can decide right now to
do three inhales
or i can just go back to breathing
reflexively i can just do that at any
moment so that the neural
arc you know real estate which is in the
brainstem that controls breathing
is in a unique position because it's at
the kind of boundary between conscious
control and unconscious control i can't
do that for my digestion i can't do that
for
most most everything that happens
internally the other thing is that
breathing controls
our level of alertness very dramatically
so the faster you breathe generally the
more alert you are the slower you
breathe the more calm you're going to be
faster you breathe meaning shorter quick
breaths or
either way
so um so we're just to take a brief um
adventure through the the neuroscience
of breathing and how it relates to brain
states and there's some fun tools in
here so forgive me for this tangent but
you have two brain areas that are
responsible for breathing one is called
for the aficionados the pre-butt singer
complex it was discovered by jack
feldman at ucla it's named after a
bottle of wine so now you people won't
forget it and it controls rhythmic
breathing
so inhale exhale inhale exhale it's just
rhythmic breathing there's another brain
area that controls breathing which is
near what's called the para facial
nucleus which involves breathing anytime
there are double inhales or double
exhales or triple inhales you say well
why would you have this second brain
area for breathing well turns out when
you're speaking or crying or coughing
you need to coordinate your breathing
with your speaking and that means
sometimes you need to take multiple
inhales or multiple exhales and this is
all happening very very fast you don't
notice
but
there's a very important discovery that
was made a few years ago by jack's lab
and by a guy named mark krasnow at
stanford
who discovered there's a set of neurons
in your brain stem mind brings them
everybody's brainstem and every animal
every mammal's brainstem it's a very
small number of neurons that controls a
specific pattern of breathing which are
called physiological size
so these are not just sides where you go
and exhale
these are size that involve doing two
inhales and then an extended exhale we
all do this you do this during sleep
any time carbon dioxide levels in your
bloodstream get too high
in order to get more oxygen into your
system
people also do this if they've been
crying or sobbing they'll do this
and then they'll exhale so what's
happening with these physiological sides
and why is this powerful so your lungs
are too big bags of air but they
actually are made up of a ton of little
sacks of air called the alveoli of the
lungs
when we are exercising or when we are
sleeping or anytime we're doing anything
these these little sacks of air
eventually start to collapse and what
happens is carbon dioxide builds up in
our system and we experience that as
stress we actually feel the impulse to
breathe because carbon dioxide levels
get too high there are neurons that
sense carbon dioxide and then
without realizing it you do the double
inhale
and then exhale typically the inhales
are done through the nose and the exhale
is done through the mouth so it looks
like
and why the second inhale well if you've
ever tried to blow up a balloon for a
kid at a kid's party or just blowing up
a balloon you sometimes blow into that
empty balloon
what do you do you do two in you do two
you go
and then it pops open so these double
inhales pop open the avioli of the lungs
they don't explode them but they pop
them open which
pulls carbon dioxide out of the
bloodstream
brings oxygen and then you offload
carbon dioxide incidentally or not so
incidentally i should say when you look
at communities of very high performers
and i'm fortunate enough to do some
consulting with some people from special
forces communities and so forth they're
very good as are you at attaching a
reward to specific behaviors in
subjective ways so growth mindset and
these dopamine rewards that we
subjectively apply are not about saying
oh you know i had a terrible day i
performed poorly but you know what it's
great i just feel great anyway it's not
about that it's not about attaching your
sense of reward to the ultimate goal
it's about attaching your sense of
reward to the fact that you're making
action steps that are generally in the
right direction the more you can reward
the effort process i didn't have the
power of concentration i hadn't read all
the good books that gun high school
students read growing up i had to
learn how to speak properly i learned
how to learn how to think properly and
really learn how to
commit to something that was very linear
and at times was very painful and and i
went to some pretty extreme things i um
you know i actually used to
set a timer
uh and i wouldn't allow myself to get
out of the chair until i was the timer
went off right so and i would experience
extreme agitation but over time i got
pretty good and now i can do long stints
of work without any breaks what's
interesting about growth mindset is that
it seems like there's some attachment of
the reward systems of the brain to the
action or the pursuit of a goal not just
achieving a goal and when we step back
and we look at
what that really entails at a
neurochemical level we have reward
systems in the brain they generally fall
into two categories they're the reward
systems that make you feel really good
with kind of the here and now and
everything that's within the confines of
your skin and the things you already
have you know love of your dog love of
your spouse
gratitude for all the things you happen
to have and that and those are generally
governed by the release of molecules
like serotonin and oxytocin okay
but then there's another reward system
which is the one that drove a lot of
human evolution which is the dopamine
reward system now dopamine is a very
misunderstood molecule it's often talked
about only in the context of reward like
i'm going to work to this goal i'm going
to build my company i'm going to you
know get tenure as a professor whatever
it is and you reach it and you get this
dopamine reward and indeed that's true
but what's often not discussed is that
dopamine is secreted enroute to rewards
while you pursue rewards
now
the ability to tap into that system
to subjectively amplify that pathway of
reward in pursuit of goals is an
absolute game changer when it comes to
things like
anything challenging that of long
duration or uncertainty or getting
through this cove you know pandemic
situation
but the amazing thing is remember the
brain only does five things and we get
to decide which of those sensations and
perceptions have relevance and which
ones don't or which ones are attached to
a goal and which ones aren't so growth
mindset in its purest form is the
attachment of these reward systems to
the effort process to the friction
process and not just to obtaining a
reward and just as a kind of final point
to that there's a very um well-known
body of literature and neuroscience at
least among neuroscientists that talks
about something called reward prediction
error and it says if you can dose the
dopamine
subjectively as you go through the
pursuit of something and then have a lot
of dopamine when you reach that thing
it's very likely that you're going to
reinforce that circuit there will be
neural plasticity and that circuit will
become stronger so the next time you
will revisit those sets of behaviors the
opposite can happen too
where you're in real anticipation of
something this is going to be great this
is going to be great this can be great
and then you reach that goal and it's
kind of underwhelming and that generally
triggers this the circuit that i
referred to earlier this kind of
disappointment or pro-depressive circuit
so dopamine
is involved in reward but it's also
involved in the pursuit of rewards and
so as you reach a milestone or as you
tell yourself
i'm on the right track this friction i'm
feeling this late night this early
morning this hard conversation with
somebody that doesn't feel good i'm
going to tell myself this is for a
larger purpose that's that subjective
insertion that abstraction that we're
talking about earlier and when you start
releasing dopamine to those kinds of
things there's essentially no limit on
the number of things you can do or the
energy to do them so just as a last last
point about dopamine when we're in
effort we're always secreting adrenaline
we're always in pursuit and it's
draining it's tiring
dopamine has this beautiful capacity to
buffer adrenaline and you know this
you've experienced this before because
if you've ever been working really
really hard maybe your team is depleted
everything's just a mess and somebody
cracks a joke and all of a sudden in an
instant it's like everything's reframed
that couldn't have been hormonal
hormones work on that on the schedule of
like hours to days to weeks it had to be
neurochemical it absolutely had to be
neurochemical and that neurochemical is
dopamine i would hide in the tower books
section uh in the evenings and i would
read everything about fitness psychology
anything i could i've always devoured
information my favorite book when i was
a kid was the encyclopedia or the
guinness book of worlds records so i was
like when i was a little kid i'd walk
around the aspen center for physics and
i would tell anyone i didn't even ask
them if they want to hear about like the
what's the world's smallest eutherian
mammal you know i would like i could
tell you all these facts that were kind
of meaningless at the time but um i've
always been fascinated by the inventory
of different animals on the planet and
their different behaviors and so
yeah voracious reader and still now
there is something called adrenal
insufficiency syndrome which is a real
medical phenomenon where the adrenals
are incapable of making these cortisol
and adrenal hormones but
the the truth is that you have enough
adrenaline and cortisol in your body to
last two lifetimes and 25 famines i mean
we were built with a lot of robustness
right this explains you know that you
know the david goggins of the world they
they you know we we all do have that
greater capacity that people talk about
the stress is very misunderstood because
people think of stress as this ancient
carryover that's very unfortunate it
kind of gets lumped with depression like
oh this is just a
flaw in our design or something but
actually stress is wonderful it actually
activates our immune system so
anytime you liberate adrenaline into
your bloodstream you also protect
yourself against infection of bacteria
and viruses because if you think about
if we had to gather food
and we didn't have it and we had to then
pack up and you know migrate long
distances you can't afford to get sick
and this is why people who work work
work work and then rest they usually get
sick when they finally stop and rest
yeah it's like the post finals
phenomenon in university or after the
season
for a game or the caretaker thing where
you're taking care of somebody who's ill
and you're just
work work work or taking care of young
children and then you finally stop to
rest you go on vacation and you get
slammed with with what is that because
you're being in your comfort zone now
are you getting stress turned off and
adrenaline
and so that these the stress response
recruits the immune
organs of the body to release killer t
cells in fact wim hof breathing i know
you're familiar with whim
of doing 20 or 30 deep inhales and
exhales
and also combined with some breath hold
type work exhale hold inhale hold is
known to stimulate adrenaline release
and the one of the better papers that's
out there scientific peer-reviewed
papers is a study published in the
proceedings the national academy of
sciences where they brought in two
groups um one group um did wim hof
breathing
the other group did just uh mindful
meditation both groups were injected
with e coli
right crazy right
it's crazy the meditators got fever
diarrhea and and um and vomiting and the
people who did wim hof
either didn't get it or got it to a much
lesser extent sluggish but that's right
they didn't right this is not an
experiment to do at home isn't this
crazy but it makes perfect sense because
it inc that breathing simulates a stress
response it stimulates cortisol and
adrenaline which signals protects the
body right which signals to the thymus
the spleen and the other you know the
the nodes of the immune system to
liberate killer cells and so when that
bacteria comes in
the system is ready for it
your body is defending against viruses
that's right disease that's right
essentially
when you create a routine of healthy
stress that's right and and we can talk
about we definitely want to
you don't want stress on all the time
sleep is really important etc but that
stress response combats
infection because it recruits immune
cells why fear why do we have fears why
do we have trauma why do we have shame
and here's the stinger it was all set up
for you in your youth i don't want to
focus on the bad but most of the stuff
when you're young you're just a passive
learning machine it's all coming in
little kids are learning three languages
with no accents flexibly they're not
even thinking about they're learning
instruments you know someone asked a
great question the other day at the
workshop wait now i know i want all that
stuff how come it's so much tougher and
there's a lot of biology that i'd be
happy to tell you about that explains
why that all shuts down after these
so-called critical periods during
development so what happens when you're
an adult and you want to change your
brain so now i'm going to get into the
stuff that's that hopefully is useful to
you
okay so these basic facts that changing
your brain in a real way as an adult
requires that you
do particular things that activate
particular chemical systems in your
brain so how do you do that right i
could tell you all about the chemicals
and i'll tell you a little bit about
them but how do you do it
okay so
this is a right here right now urgent
situation car wreck it's terrible you
can imagine any other trauma in its
place when that happens a little area in
the base of the brain the name isn't
important but if you care it's called
nucleus basalis
does its job which is just it's an alert
system it puts all its attention on
right here right now get everybody safe
it's your alert system and it has this
effect of dumping out
a certain chemical called acetylcholine
at specific locations in the brain that
are paired with that experience and
forever that experience will be
traumatic unless something else is done
okay so there's some nuances and details
to this but that pretty much summarizes
it has been replicated many many times
in dozens of studies you can pair pretty
much any experience with stimulation of
nucleus basalis this thing in the in the
base of the brain and that experience
will be mapped or remapped in your brain
as an adult and that's remarkable it's
also exciting because then i someone
like me says well then how do i change
my experience how do i change the
meaning of what happens how do i change
something from traumatic to positive
the good news is nucleus basalis is just
a slave to whatever
is exciting traumatic it likes emotion
it like it likes peaks and lows
and so if acetylcholine is released that
means you can massively change your
brain at that moment with whatever's
paired with it and so when you get into
a peak state here you're jumping up and
down or in a really low state and you're
thinking how miserable something is you
have to be really careful because those
are the things that you're wiring in all
right so you can move to a state like
this about driving later if you form
enough associations with driving to
really eliminate to override the fear
you need to create a positive experience
in its place so how do you do that
so i'm going to tell you that the way
you do that is not to think too hard and
to not verbalize things too much and
this is coming from someone who spent 25
years three times a week on a couch
letting subconscious things geyser up
and that's where i really learned that
it was really the things that you don't
realize that have the potential to have
the most impact but this power of
emotion the ability to couple really
strong emotions with things is so useful
if you want to change your brain for the
better and the way you do that
is clear in the physical space we all
know this story there are many news
cases like this woman's child stuck
under a car super human strength
we heard a lot of amazing stories about
desperation jj's story was one of
desperation she's like no i'm not going
to accept failure because failure in the
case in the case she was describing was
potentially the death of her child so
desperation is a strong one and it's
motivate motivated by fear but what if
you're not in a desperate state and you
really want to do something in that case
there's something remarkable and then we
should and we should ask ourselves why
are children such great passive learners
they're not trying they're just learning
they're coming home with all sorts of
things sometimes things you don't want
them to come home with
right it's because they have this
element of play and what is play play
isn't just movement although it includes
movement it's giving things everything
you've got but keeping it in perspective
it's that sweet spot of enjoying life
and trying really really hard at it at
the same time it's essentially what we
all
strive for and there are these
incredible cases throughout history
famous scientists because i grew up in a
house where people you know revered
scientists like like richard feynman
nobel prize winner he's most famous for
bongo drumming naked on the roof of
caltech and he became an amazing artist
in his 60s and he developed all sorts of
other skills and he always had this
childlike way of looking at the world he
never let himself get stuck in his ways
never became a curmudgeon and a
remarkable man and that's something that
i if you come away with nothing else i
encourage you to do that you want your
brain to change stay light stay loose
but give it everything you've got can a
person make it
so they never
get depressed they never react to
their perception their people's actions
towards them where they never get to a
state of uh i don't feel good i'm
feeling more depressed
i'm in a dark place now i'm stuck in
this place is there a way that we could
ever
defend ourselves against negative
stressors negative emotions or are we
just
are they do we need them as well to have
contrast in life well there's sort of
two views on this um i'll reveal mine
after i um sort of
explain the two views one is that these
states i guess i'm i'm automatically
calling things like depression a state
of mind
so when i say state of mind i mean brain
and body because your body is really
feeling
it's like the brain is connected to the
body right and so if you're saying
internally the thought of like
i'm depressed i don't feel good or i'm
sad or lonely or i'm not good enough the
body's going to react is that what i'm
understanding absolutely the body's
going to manifest what the mind is
telling you absolutely the thought the
idea you're gonna be like i'm sad i'm
not good enough you're gonna shrink
right is that right that's right i mean
they're really two forms of depression
um sometimes they're intermixed but one
is anxiety-associated depression and you
you if you've ever experienced it or
anyone that's experienced it they feel
agitation in their body
and their mind races but in their body
so the body is recruited
there are also depressive states
that people feel very fatigued and
exhausted it's been overwhelmed and they
also experience that in their body
the idea of getting out of bed in the
morning is hard um
motivating to exercise doing the sorts
of things that we know
are powerful for pushing back on
depression
so
the body is recruited i think
most people would say that
depressive states are bad when they
bring down the baseline on life i
just to as a brief aside anytime there's
a question about mental health or
addiction or trauma or anything
one could look at it and make up some
argument of low evolutionarily this
makes sense we all get depressed but
we have to be fair to the person
experiencing it of course and have
sensitivity that some behaviors will
keep the baseline of our life steady
meaning job relationships etc will
continue as they are other activities
will tend to improve the baseline on our
life job activities relationship etc
will will improve and then there's some
things like heroin
which
does very quickly we can predict that
very quickly the baseline on life is
going to creep down regardless of who
that person is right so people say can
you get addicted to water well maybe but
i have to drink a lot of water before
the baseline of my life starts to go
down so sure it feels uncomfortable
that's just like man i'm so bloated
exactly so we tend to throw around
things like addiction and depression a
little loosely so yeah i think that it's
fair to say that depression is wired
into us as a possible state that we can
all fall into
but that it's very important in my
opinion that humans have tools
to remove themselves from that state
of course to avoid tragedies like
suicide but also because when the
baseline on someone's life goes down far
enough
they find it increasingly hard to do the
sorts of things that are going to get
them out of depression so you or i could
say so they stay in that state of
depression that's right it's too hard to
go work it's too hard to change my habit
of eating healthier so i'm going to stay
i'm going to keep eating ice cream which
is going to make my body
you know depressed that's right right if
i keep eating bad foods if i keep
staying up till 4 a.m if i keep staying
in a toxic relationship i want to feel
depressed that's right and eventually
because of this very
um
inseparable relationship between the
brain and body eventually what happens
is that because the brain controls the
body but also the body can control the
brain
people lose the ability to intervene in
this depressive process so you or i
could say look
if someone who's depressed they what
they need to do is get up early get some
light in their eyes
get some movement i know you put this
information out there which i love
because these the those tips are
grounded
in uh they're not even tips they're
really tools and they're very powerful
because they're grounded in excellent
science you get that dopamine release
early in the day that's anti-depressive
you time your sleep better when you get
sun in your eyes and you get movement
early in the day
for most people that's accessible and
they should be they absolutely should be
doing it everyone should be doing that
but for people who are far enough down
that path of depression because the body
and the mind have this relationship
that's so close
there is a crossover point where
they really can't do those activities
because they're so far deep in the
depression the body won't do what they
decide to do
and so now i'm not trying to give anyone
a pass because ultimately we are all
responsible for our own mental health
certainly
adults more than kids but you know we're
all responsible for our own mental
health and only we can direct our own
brain changes that's the that's the
stinger once we're you know 25 years and
older
we are the only ones that can change our
brain and we can talk about
neuroplasticity if you like but the
depressed person
has to take responsibility for their
behavior but this is why it's so
important to catch this brain body
relationship early and build
routines that keep one out of depression
for everything that happens to us from
the time that we're born until the time
we die
but that really boils down to only five
things
the nervous system
has the responsibility of sensation so
sensing the physical events in the
environment we have these so-called
receptors in the eyes and the ears and
the nose and the mouth on the skin
that take physical entities in the in
the universe that are real fixed
non-negotiable things like sound waves
and photons of light and chemicals in
the environment traveling that make it
into our nose and things like that and
convert those into the second thing
which is perceptions
so the nervous system's responsibility
is to take those sensations
which are non-negotiable and
perceive certain ones and not others so
for instance right now until i say you
know what's the sensation of your feet
contacting the floor or the bottoms of
your shoes you weren't thinking about it
but those pressure receptors were being
engaged the entire time so your
perception is like a window or a
spotlight that's very much linked to
attention
then there are emotions often called
feelings
and those are really designed
to push us down particular avenues of
perception and
the next thing which are thoughts
okay so we've got sensation perception
feelings and then there are thoughts
which really have a lot to do with what
we're perceiving and the way we're
organizing those perceptions what they
mean and generally that's put into the
context of what we already know or
memories
and then the fifth thing is behaviors
or actions and of course neurons are
responsible for generating actions and
they're really two kinds of actions
there are the actions that you generate
reflexively like your breathing and your
heart rate right now are largely
reflexive or you could decide troll of
your respiration
and be make it voluntary right and not
just reflexive so those five things
sensations perceptions feelings thoughts
and actions really encompass all of our
life experience and that's from the very
mundane of getting up in the morning and
brushing your teeth to the most
awe-inspiring
uh goal-motivated
uh pinnacle moments of your life the
nervous system not the immune system not
the digestive system all of which are
important but the nervous system meaning
the brain spinal cord and the
connections with the body and the
connections from the body back to the
brain and spinal cord are responsible
for all of that everything that happens
to you your entire experience i don't
care what anyone says i don't care what
alignment the earth is in
everything is happening because your
brain has these three jobs and all of
your experiences filtered through that
thing in your head that pile of cells
that's arranged in a very specific way
that we're still trying to understand
called your brain
just like we could be talking about the
heart whose job is to pump blood so i
want to describe just how the brain
works in three basic ways two of which
you've heard about before we all heard
the lizard brain the thing that freaks
you out when you think there's someone
standing in the corner and they turn on
the light there's nobody or if you were
to come up on a car wreck and all of a
sudden your heart's pumping your brain
is very good at that stuff and that's
great that's why you're alive at this
moment it is an unerring unfailing
system keeping you alive your lizard
brain and it's generally designed to
keep you alive and to scare you from
doing things that would hurt you it's a
shame because i would have liked it to
be generally good at making me feel good
all the time but that's generally not
what it's good at and i'm stealing from
the great
tony robbins who says you know there's
paved roads to fear and misery and
cobblestone or dirt roads to happiness
and that's true at the level of
neuroanatomy you don't have a whole lot
of your brain devoted to happiness you
got a lot of your brain designed to keep
you safe so anxieties and fears come
about a lot easier you need to combat
those
we're all getting better at that
thinking planning imagining and doing is
the other kind of end of the spectrum i
talked about that and then there's the
one that really counts right which is
this thing in the middle which is the
way that those things are connected what
do you think depends on how you feel
what you feel depends on how you think
we know this now there's kind of common
knowledge
and it's these maps of your experience
it depends on what happened to you and
how you view the world and we know this
at a psychological level neuroscientists
sometimes talk like this they often
don't i'm in the minority but there's a
lot of neuroanatomy there's a lot of
powerful neuroscience to support this
what do i mean by your maps of
experience i mean what happened to you
shapes how you view the world and so
what's important is how you change how
you view the world if you want to go
forward beyond what would just how you
were programmed let's say it was
me realizing i'm living in this squat
where i've got a pet ferret my
girlfriend's gone she broke up with me
she was smart enough to break up with me
you know um i'm getting in fights i'm
working at a bagel shop i'm barely
making ends me and at that point i just
made the decision i just said okay
look i'm i'm not gonna be a professional
athlete i think i'm pretty good at
memorizing things i think i have an
interest in people
i'm going to just
decide i just decided to do school i
decided that was that was the track so
like some people picked the military
because it's like if you you know what
to expect at least in terms of the the
you know the passages that you're going
to go through and for me that was school
and so i hadn't decided to get back in
school i moved into a studio apartment
by myself i quit partying completely i
didn't go to parties i got
really serious about fitness so i just
started running and lifting weights
and i studied you went like henry
rollins style i did yeah i did it's a
lot of self-awareness you know i mean
people go into the military because on
some level i mean some people do because
there there's some yearning for for
having that structure imposed upon their
lives but you
you constructed that
that kind of um structure for yourself
yeah i think i was really afraid i think
i was like you know and i and these days
you know because my lab studies fear and
i get into this whole thing around
mindsets people always ask me like is it
better to do something from a place of
love or fear like
depends and at that point fear was the
best motivator for me
and i just basically worked like crazy
the brain is basically designed to be
customized in the early part of life and
then to implement those algorithms and
that circuitry for the rest of your of
its life
and so the brain can change in adulthood
and it can change provided that there's
an emphasis on some perceptual event so
in other words if you want to change
your brain as an adult let's say you
want to be less anxious you want to
learn a new language you want to be more
functional in some way presumably
the key thing is to bring
focus to some particular perception
of something that's happening during the
learning process and the reason for that
is that there's a neurochemical system
involving acetylcholine
and it comes from these two little
nuclei down in the base of the brain
called nucleus basalis
all day long you're doing things in a
reflexive way
but when you do something and you think
about it very intensely acetylcholine is
released from basalis at the precise
neurons that were involved in that
behavior and it marks those for change
during sleep or during deep rest later
so for people that want to change their
brain
the power of focus is really the entry
point and the ability to access deep
rest and sleep because most people don't
realize this but neuroplasticity is
triggered by intense focus
but neuroplasticity occurs during deep
sleep and rest one of the things that's
really important also to think about how
the brain works in terms of plasticity
and all this stuff is
what the brain really wants to do is
also pass as much of what it does after
reflexive behavior as possible
so
yeah so when we're talking about focus i
think it can get a little bit vague but
it might be useful think about like what
exactly is focus and what triggers
plasticity so the brain loves to be able
to just do things pick up
coffee cups and drink and walk and talk
and do things and not put much energy
into it when we decide to focus what the
brain really does is it switches on a
set of circuits that involve the frontal
cortex and nucleus basalis and some
others and it's trying to understand
duration
how long something's going to last path
what's going to happen and outcome what
ultimately is going to happen so
duration path and outcome you know the
the events of early 2020 are a good
example of this one of the reasons why
it's so exhausting to be alive in 2020
is because we are now having to pay
attention to duration path and outcome
how long is this thing going to last
when are
you know when are they going to open up
all businesses did i touch that door
handle does it matter you know right who
are the experts are there any experts
you know there are a lot of questions
whereas normally we can just move
through life without having to do all
that analysis
so
if it's a simple example like trying to
learn a new language or a new motor
skill or a new way of conceptualizing
something maybe somebody's in a
therapeutic process and they're trying
to work through a trauma or something
like that duration path and outcome
is
built into the networks of the brain we
can do that very easily but it takes
work and it almost has a feeling of
underlying agitation and frustration and
that's because the circuits that turn on
before acetylcholine are of the stress
system so when you or i decide we're
going to learn something and really dig
in
norepinephrine which is adrenaline is
secreted in the brain stem and in the
body and it brings about a state of
alertness
then our attention which is mostly a
diffuse light is brought to a particular
duration path in outcome analysis this
would be thinking about what somebody is
saying what are they really trying to
say a hard passage of reading
a hard you know set of math problems you
know a challenging physical workout
when you do that these two systems have
to work very hard and the adult brain
doesn't really want to change the
algorithms it learned in childhood but
if you do those two things you have
alertness and focus the acetylcholine
and the norepinephrine converge to mark
those synapses for change
and so dir so the way to think about
neural plasticity if one wants to change
their brain is bring about the most
intense concentration you can to
something
and then later bring about the least
amount of concentration to that thing
forward movement provided it doesn't
endanger you or kill you is
absolutely the remedy for fear stress
and all and at least in the clinical
literature to these sort of trauma
events you know that that people carry
with them for many years of course
trauma needs to be dealt with hopefully
with a professional but we can all apply
these mechanisms and these neurochemical
reward schedules so the the study that
you're referring to is a beautiful one
um
there's a classic study where
researchers not my lab put two rats or
you could do this with mice into a tube
and the tendency is for them to try and
push one or the other one out one always
wins and pushes the other one out we
call the one that got pushed out the
loser the one that pushed him out the
winner
here are the interesting things about
this
first of all the winner
will tend to win with other in other
battles even though these are just
pushing battles
more because it simply won the time
before the loser by losing will tend to
lose and some people say oh well that
explains a lot about society etc well
here's where it gets really interesting
you can even take a mouse or a rat and
push it from behind and make it the
winner and then on subsequent trials
where you're not pushing it it will tend
to win more often so the win doesn't
even have to come from itself
so last year there was a very important
paper published about this where a set
of researchers just said well what is it
like what is this winning circuit and
this losing circuit enough with the
demonstration that this happens like
what's happening on what's under the
hood and so they went into the brain and
they identified
a brain area which is part of the
frontal cortex the area that we
typically think about planning action
executive function all the kind of high
level stuff
and what they
discovered was this brain area is more
active in the winter
than in the loser in fact they could
take the loser and over stimulate this
area and turn the losers into winners
now it gets even more ridiculous than
that if you quiet this brain area
winners become losers okay
and
and if you take a winner
and let's say at this tube battle and
you put them into say a cold environment
with a bunch of other mice and you have
just a warm corner mice don't like to be
cold and you say who gets the warm
corner right who gets the luxury spot
it's always the winner so it even breaks
down at the level of social interactions
and so you say okay all right now we
know that's this brain area it's it's
this one area of the frontal cortex but
what's it actually doing right okay
what's it actually tran what how can we
translate this turns out this brain area
that's responsible and required for
winning in this series of experiments
is actually driving up the level of
activation
what you and i would call agitation or
stress to the point where that animal is
more likely to move forward it's simply
taking stress which is
wired into us in order to make us feel
agitated instead of suppressing us you
know instead of saying you know i'm just
going to sit here i'm overwhelmed i'm
just going to move into action so
there's a circuit for winning there's a
the same circuit when it's
hypoactive not active enough is what
causes
losing in these competitive scenarios
and similarly there's a circuit for
quitting there's an a norepinephrine
circuit in the brain stem this was
published in the last couple years
showing that when animals or people are
in constant effort eventually that level
of norepinephrine gets so high that it
triggers a circuit that shuts down the
motor control over the limbs and you
just say that's it i give up i'm done so
these mechanisms were hardwired into us
we all have them whether or not it's
from evolution mother nature god the
universe it is it's irrelevant to the
discussion that these circuits exist in
everybody and i think it's a select few
people who really understand that
forward action
is what drives these circuits it's
the ability to take that agitation
stress agitation increase our focus and
they bias us for movement and nature
wanted that they want us to move forward
in the face of challenge not to be quiet
we weren't sitting around battling
tigers and saber-toothed tigers all the
time more likely we were in caves and we
were getting hungry and we had to go out
and search for things agitation and
stress were designed to get us up and
move us and when we try and fight that
too much and we try and quiet that
stress
that actually can be problematic you
have to decide are you going to try and
quiet stress or are you going to
actually lean into action that's
critical choice point for everybody
who's experienced anything negative or
positive for that matter the mind plays
an important role in interpreting
whether or not it's overwhelming or
tolerable so intense breathing like
tumor breathing or ice baths or cold
showers or intense exercise like you
know high intensity interval training
type stuff
teaches the mind to be comfortable in
these higher stress states where in
other words it teaches people to be
comfortable when they have a lot of
adrenaline in their body this is
basically stress inoculation but stress
inoculation is not about not getting
stressed it's actually about divorcing
the mind-body relationship a bit the
nervous system is designed to
orchestrate all the processes in the
body not just thinking and not just
behavior and really can be divided into
five things so
there's
sensation and sensation is really bound
or restricted by the receptors in the
body so
receptors in the eye that perceive
photons light energy
receptors in the skin that perceive
pressure you know touch receptors
smell taste hearing etc
and the interesting thing about
sensation and the fact that the nervous
system needs to pay attention to
sensation is it's non-negotiable
the nervous system of humans is designed
to extract physical phenomenon from the
universe that are non-negotiable photons
of light i can't see in the infrared
with my eyes and i can't see ultraviolet
light with my eyes i can't perceive that
because i don't have the receptors for
it
so
you know other animals can perceive some
of those things but that leads us to the
next thing which is perception which is
which sensations are you paying
attention to so all the time you're
sensing things like right now your feet
are sensing the contact with your shoes
but you're not thinking about it until i
say that and then you shift your
perception right so perception is like
the spotlight so the brain wants to
constantly bring in sensation it's
non-negotiable what's coming in it's
just dependent on your environment
perception is negotiable you can control
that because i just said shoes and you
thought about your feet and there you
are
then there are feelings which
can be a little bit nebulous but
feelings are a link between our emotion
and
it generally invokes the body sensations
in the body and concepts in the mind of
what those sensations are about that's
really what emotions are animals
definitely experience them i'm kind of
appalled to think that 10 years ago
people like do animals have emotions of
course they have emotions right because
those are bodily sensations merged with
some perception so of course they do
and then there's thoughts and thoughts
are interesting because thoughts happen
spontaneously think about like a web
browser that's constantly giving you
pop-ups
but thoughts can also be deliberate so
you and i can decide right now that
we're gonna think about a plan for
something or we're gonna think about
what's going on in the world
so thoughts happen spontaneously and
they can be deliberate and then the
final thing is behaviors and actions so
the nervous system is responsible for
sensation perception feelings thoughts
and behaviors
and what's interesting we start to think
about that as you're like okay that's a
lot
but what is the nervous system really
trying to accomplish like on any given
day or at any moment what's it trying to
accomplish and it's really trying to
accomplish one thing which is to take
perceptions of the outside world
and merge those with perceptions of the
inside world what we call interoception
and to link those
in a way that's
operating on our environment in the
appropriate way so what do i mean by
that so if i'm feeling anxious and i'm
in a very calm environment i'm going to
perceive that rapid heart rate and kind
of feeling of agitation in my body as
inappropriate for the moment
right and my goal then as a as an
organism is to adjust my my level of
what they call autonomic arousal or
alertness down
if i'm in a at a great party or i'm at a
wedding or it's a celebration or i'm at
a protest or you know um
then i might feel that
my level of alertness is appropriate for
my environment so the nervous system is
in this constant dynamic
interaction with the outside world and
trying to figure that out
one way that this can be kind of
conceptualized is there's an emerging
idea that's kind of interesting about
impatience
so we've all had the feeling of being
impatient some people are far more
patient than others but if you've ever
been in line at the store
and you feel like something's going very
slowly you know the person in front of
you is taking a long time they're doing
some returns you're getting kind of
impatient maybe breathing in a mask and
you're like oh like you're you know
what's the idea is that if you're
getting a certain frequency of pulses
from your body and if those pulses are
coming in quickly like you're perceiving
your yourself that enteroception quickly
it's like pulse pulse pulse pulse you're
going to be more geared towards your
internal representation and then you're
seeing what's going on in the outside
world and it seems like it's going very
slowly
but there are other times when you're in
line at the store someone's getting some
returns and you're texting on your phone
you've had a great day you've had a
great run your family's in great shape
and you're fine why well the frequency
of those pulses that interoception is
matched pretty well to your outside
environment
and so impatience is really when you're
in internal sort of metronome
is not matched well to the external
environment
there are other times when you're
feeling like your internal metronome is
tick tick tick and you've got a million
things coming at you through email or
text you've got a bunch of things and
you're feeling overwhelmed and tired
well in either case there's nothing
right or wrong it's just
your body and your brain are trying to
say what's going on in the outside world
and how well matched am i to it right so
if you think about some of the the sort
of core practices of mindfulness and
self-regulation of like focusing on
breathing or focusing on on you know
state of mind a lot of that is trying to
bring more awareness to your internal
state
but
what our brain is normally doing when
our eyes are open and we're interacting
in the world is we're constantly trying
to update our internal state to match
external demands of the world and this
harkens back to a you know like a really
early design of all nervous systems
which is how do you take an organism
that needs certain things food water
mates reproduction shelter how do you
move that organism how do you create a
system that will do that in best
relation to the environment
and so what mother nature has done is
designed a syst a series of systems
let's just take agitation and stress for
one if an animal or a human is very
thirsty you feel kind of agitated might
get up and get a drink of water if
you're very thirsty it can put you into
a state of panic if you're extremely
thirsty and water is a limited resource
you might even result to violence to get
it or negotiation of some sort that you
wouldn't if you were calmer so the
stress and agitation we're designed to
actually mobilize the body to take us in
the direction of something that's
adaptive so you can start to see these
kind of core elements
of
what the brain and nervous system do
sensation perception feeling thought and
action and this
constant challenge of trying to match
our internal state to the external real
estate the outside world and you start
to see that the sensations that we call
stress or impatience or calm
are really the result of that those
attempts that the nervous system is
trying to perform this is what you've
done this is what people from elite
special forces can do they know how to
make small
simple
physical steps in the real world
that allow them to build on these reward
circuitries but they don't get
delusional about how they're doing they
they know they keep the end in mind but
they get very micro they move the
horizon in very close and so
if you can move the horizon to something
you know you can complete and you reward
that
you essentially are where you were
before
you're just as strong if not stronger
but you're heading in the direction you
need to go you're not depleting you're
not spending out anything and it feels a
little weird because none of us like to
reward things that aren't external to
what extent does our subjective
narrative the story the story we tell
ourselves actually means something for
the body
and to what extent does the body
actually means something for the
subjective narrative so
this gets into some areas of work that
we're doing now and so i do want to
highlight that it's ongoing work but i
think
you know the old narrative meaning a few
ten years ago was that if you're feeling
depressed just smile the reason i call
it a brain body contract early on is
that
their the brain and the body are
constantly in dialogue so
you know the idea that when we're
depressed we tend to be in more
defensive type postures when we're
feeling good we tend to be in more like
relaxed and extended postures all true
but it does not mean that just by
occupying the extended posture that i'm
going to completely shift the mind right
that's a first step think about like two
interlocking gears it's one gear that
turns the other but then they need to
kind of dance together before you can
get the whole system going and how do
you get it to dance together exactly so
subjective
there is one way in which subjective
thought and deliberate thought is very
powerful over states of mind and body to
answer your question can you think your
way out of the ice bath being cold
so a couple things that are important
first of all just to
go a little deeper on what thoughts are
thoughts happen spontaneously all the
time they're popping up like a poorly
filtered internet connection
but
thoughts can also be deliberately
introduced for instance right now
i can say
okay
have a thought
that um just decide to write your name
and your you can do that i'm going to
decide write my name and you can do it
so that's a deliberate thought which
says that you can introduce thoughts so
i think it's very hard to control
negative thoughts directly by trying to
suppress them
they ten generally they tend to just
want to continue to geyser up all the
time but we can introduce a positive
thought an ability to control your
levels of stress in real time is
extremely powerful
it turns out you can do this using
physiology and neuroscience
your breathing can directly impact your
heart rate and your level of stress or
calm here's how it works
when you inhale your diaphragm moves
down
this creates more space in your thoracic
cavity and your heart actually gets a
little bit bigger as a consequence the
rate of blood flow through that larger
heart volume
slows down
a signal is sent from a group of neurons
on your heart called the sinoatrial node
that signal goes up to the brain and
your brain sends a signal to speed the
heart up
in other words inhaling
speeds your heart rate up
the opposite is true as well when you
exhale your diaphragm moves up
your heart gets a little bit smaller
because there's a little bit less space
in your thoracic cavity as a consequence
blood flows more quickly through that
smaller volume the sinoatrial node
registers that and sends a signal to
your brain
and the brain sends a signal to slow the
heart down so in other words inhaling
speeds your heart rate up exhaling slows
your heart rate down so if you want to
speed up your heart rate and be more
alert
inhale more or make those inhales more
vigorous more intense if you want to
calm down
you can do that quickly by making your
exhales slightly longer than your
inhales or making them more vigorous
this doesn't require any breath work
this is something that you can do in
real time and that's what's called
respiratory sinus arrhythmia that's the
technical phrase it's also the basis of
what's called heart rate variability or
hrv but all you need to remember is
inhaling deeper and longer will speed
your heart rate up exhaling longer and
more intensely will slow your heart rate
down and will allow you to calm down in
real time acetylcholine is the
neurochemical that we want to think
about anytime we're talking about neural
plasticity and in particular attention
high attentional states so everyone
knows that the brain is very plastic
early in life so from birth until about
age 25 you can learn so much for better
or for worse i always say the downside
is that early in life you're you have
less control over your life
circumstances but your brain is very
plastic so there's a you know dark and
light to that later in life you have a
lot more control generally over your
life circumstances but the brain becomes
less plastic however
we know based on nobel prize winning
work and
recent work in addition to that
that the
neuromodulator acetylcholine is secreted
when we pay attention to something very
specific it acts as sort of a spotlight
in the brain making certain synapses the
connections between neurons more active
and more likely to be active again than
others so when you hear that song that
you love so much and it moves you and
you feel dopamine being pulsed into your
body that's a real thing you're actually
getting dopamine secretion you form that
deep association with that and
acetylcholine draws your attention to
that and that song is essentially wired
in a very indelible way into your
nervous system multiple you can probably
even with certain songs you can feel
your body start to energize because of
course the brain
through connections with your muscles
controls your body
so
for things that are traumatic or
negative what we're really talking about
is neuroplasticity that's focused on
unlearning and most of the therapies for
this whether or not it's emdr eye
movement desensitization reprocessing or
it's traditional psychoanalysis and
psychotherapy or it's somatic embodied
release big you know kundalini breathing
type almost all of those are designed to
do something which is to bring the
person or you bring yourself
into a state of heightened alertness
right you can't do this stuff when
you're sort of half asleep heightened
alertness and then focusing your
attention on the traumatic or negative
event this is the way that it works and
then pairing that was something new you
know traditionally this was done with
things like nlp or in talk therapy where
people would feel
the relation the positive relationship
with the therapist that was kind of the
main rationale
in association with this very traumatic
sometimes even you know shameful type
events and the idea is that you you
would simultaneously have those two
experiences the negative one and the
feeling of safety and you would rewire
those circuitries i actually believe
that can work but it can take
a lot of times it can take a lot of
visits to the therapist which is not to
say it's bad it's just not everyone has
access to those resources
things like eye movement desensitization
reprocessing simply moving the eyes
laterally while recounting these
negative events the woman who devised
this
figured out
that somehow when people recount these
traumatic experiences when they're doing
these lateralized eye movements not
vertical eye movements they
somehow separate out the negative
emotions and i thought for years people
would ask me about this stuff tom and i
thought this is ridiculous first of all
i'm a vision scientist and i work on
stress it's like there's no way and then
i really ate my words because four
papers two inhumans two in mice and then
a fifth paper published in nature which
is kind of our super bowl of scientific
publishing
showed that these lateralized eye
movements quiet the amygdala they
actually suppress activation of this
threat detection center in the amygdala
and why would that be true ah so this is
really where it gets cool turns out
because of
when the way that we view the visual
world when we move through space when
our head moves or when we walk and
things flow past us that these
lateralized eye movements
are what happens when you move forward
in space when you're walking when you're
moving forward towards something and
that suppresses
activation of the amygdala now you say
why well okay so then 2018
my laboratory did an experiment there
was actually graduates in my laboratory
where we're looking at fear in this case
we're looking at fear to big looming
objects that either trigger freezing or
running and hiding there's a brain area
that's in your brain and my brain that
mice also have that triggers a third
option not run and hide not freeze but
forward confrontation this is the no i'm
gonna fight i'm gonna move forward in
the face of diversity this is the growth
mindset i'm going to lean into friction
and it turns out that this circuit is
linked to the dopamine reward pathway
when we move forward
in the face of a threat and obviously we
want to do this in healthy adaptive ways
we suppress activity of the amygdala
through physical action of moving
forward and there's a signal sent to the
areas of the brain that control dopamine
reward
those reward centers then trigger the
release of dopamine to reward forward
effort in the face of stress or threat
so when you hear about people saying
look take some physical action when
you're feeling exhausted take some
forward physical action when you're
feeling overwhelmed by this traumatic
experience now that could be in the form
of a walk in the now this therapist she
figured out with emdr because you can't
take people walking around for therapy
sessions she figured out that these
lateralized eye movements are what
trigger suppression of the amygdala and
it makes perfect sense because the
amygdala this threat detection center in
our brain it doesn't connect to the
limbs so how does it know if you're
moving forward well because the eyes are
moving you have these reflexive eye
movements that move anytime you're
moving through space
so to make this a little more succinct
it's really forward movement action
pushing yourself across that threshold
not only rewards you but it suppresses
activity of the fear centers in the
brain and these are ancient hardwired
mechanisms these aren't hacks these are
things that mother nature installed in
us i'm a big fan of wellness and and i
think it's a great community but it
tends to run in absolutes and there and
there aren't a lot of operational
definitions as we say in science and i
what i love about your questions you're
asking for the really getting to the
meat of things asking for the
operational definitions one of the most
dangerous ideas in wellness and in
popular psychology is that your body
hears every thought you have what a
terrible thing to put on people you know
what wow what a challenging thing i
don't think people should try and
suppress their negative thoughts i think
there is great value however to
introducing positive thought schemes now
the reason is not because i think it's
just because i think so but because
there's actually a neurochemical basis
for controlling stress and actually
making stress more tolerable and
extending one's ability to be in bouts
of effort and that relates to the
dopamine pathway
so the molecule dopamine is a reward
it's
released in the brain when you win a
game you you know close a deal you
someone like you
someone likes your photo the great love
of your life you complete something
but
most of our dopamine release is not from
achieving goals it's actually released
when we are enroute to our goals we're
in pursuit of our goals and we think
we're on the right path is one
meditation very short five minutes where
for one breath
one breath you close your eyes and go
internal and you get behind and some
people call it the third eye right i'm
gonna get the the language wrong but we
all know what we're talking about you
get inside your breath
and then the second thing you do is you
focus on something at a short distance
there's a powerful system in your brain
when you focus both eyes on a single
point like a watchmaker making a watch
or you're reading that state is
accessing very specific channels in your
brain that are very different from the
one that when you close your eyes okay
and it's called a virgin's eye movement
when you put both your eyes on the same
thing and then the last one is the one
that we get a lot of here that feeling
awesome feeling when you go out to the
beach or you're on the top of a mountain
or you look at the horizon or you arrive
in new york city if you're me and you
just go oh my god and you're defocused
and that's when you're these ideas the
creativity
kind of spontaneously geysers up from
below but then you have to get back and
you need to get to work on something and
so the what's been very powerful and
we're going to put we're putting
patients through this or
subjects in brain imaging is this way of
accessing all these different brain
states is really about accessing
different notions of space and time
trying to get access to your whole brain
and it's a short meditation i recommend
just one breath at each of these kind of
stations
in your mind
up close and focusing on your hand and
out and i'll repeat that a few times
during my morning or maybe once or twice
during the day it's quick and we're
getting remarkable feedback
from the people that are doing this
about the kind of state that it puts
them in both engaged and present with
the bigger picture and in the end it's
all about the bigger picture right
because it's about not just what you do
with your life but how you're going to
create good in the world bring as much
focus to a behavior
or to a thought or to an action pattern
and there has to be a sense of urgency
so what newton lab showed in another lab
at ucsf mike merzinick's lab showed is
that if there's a serious contingency
like in order to get your ration of food
each day you have to learn this thing
the degree of plasticity is remarkable
right but if there isn't an incentive it
just isn't going to happen so these
circuits in the brain that mother nature
set up
are designed to be anchored to a real
need and people always say to me well
should i do something out of love and a
real desire to learn or should it be out
of fear but either one works the sense
of urgency is just acetylcholine it's
norepinephrine that's all it is it
doesn't the brain doesn't have a
recognition of whether or not something
is pleasurable or not until later once
you start accomplishing your goal the
reward systems like dopamine start
kicking in but
i think if people are interested in
modifying their brain for the better at
least some you know top contour
understanding of how urgency and focus
must converge
for that to happen can be useful because
i think there's a lot of attention paid
to whether or not something feels like
flow or whether or not it's what i call
highly desirable right or whether or not
you can you can eat a plant out of the
ground that will magically put your
brain into a state of plasticity and the
answer is yes such plants exist
but what's missing is the focus
component if that work is not done with
a particular end goal in mind you'll get
plasticity but you'll get plasticity in
a kind of across the board it's like
learning nine length learning a little
bit of nine languages all at once is not
going to make you
speak coherently in any one of them
so focus is the key
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there